make sure
that your body is very comfortable
if there are any tension spots in your
body that may have come from a difficult
dream during the night
just breathe into that area
and let it go
feel how comfortable it is
for your body
to be
where it is
feel the warmth
and the peace
[Music]
and know
that today
will be a new day
such as you have never had before
i know that you have some general plans
for the day and you know what some of
the experiences will be
but not all of them
when we awaken in the morning
we never know
exactly how the day will end
delightful surprises
and wonderful adventures
are before us
[Music]
all of your thoughts
create your future
[Music]
every thought you think
is creating your future
now it really doesn't matter what sort
of thoughts you used to think in the
past
in all those mornings you awakened to
before
the only thing that matters
is the kind of thoughts
that you are choosing
to think now
in this
very moment
together now
let's release from our consciousness
all
fear and anxiety
[Music]
all anger
and resentment
all guilt
and the need for punishment
let's dissolve all sadness and jealousy
[Music]
just let it go
those are not the thoughts
we are going to use to create this new
day
this is a new day
and a new beginning
[Music]
feel the air
as it goes in and out of your body
[Music]
it's such a miracle
the way your body breathes itself
the air comes into the lungs
then it is sent over to the heart where
it mingles with the blood
and this oxygenated blood is circulated
throughout your body
through all the veins and arteries
down to the tiniest little capillaries
bathing
and soaking
and nourishing
every cell
in your body
you don't even have to think about how
to do this
there is an intelligence within your
body
that takes care of it for you
it breathes your body
it beats your heart
it digests your food
[Music]
this intelligence
enables you to see
to walk
to hold things to communicate with
others
[Music]
and to love
there are so many things in our lives
that we take for granted
we so seldom take time out to be
thankful and grateful
for the many miracles we have in our
everyday lives
[Music]
and for the miracles that we call our
bodies
too often
we only concentrate on what we do not
have
[Music]
it blesses our future
to be thankful for what we do have now
it opens the way
for the good to flow in
in ever increasing abundance
[Music]
let us begin with appreciating the very
bed we have slept in all night
think of how warm and comfortable it has
kept your body
while you slept
and did your dream work and refreshed
your mind and your body
thank your bed
[Music]
then bless the furniture in your home
that comforts your body
and fulfills various necessary functions
and conveniences
we all have a favorite piece of
furniture
have you ever thanked it for being there
for you
do that now
then think of the miracle of the
electric light in your home
how wonderful it is to have it
think of all the things that you can use
electricity for
remember our appliances are extensions
of ourselves
and just as our relationships with other
people are more wonderful when we are
loving
so it is with the relationships we have
with what we call things
appliances and automobiles do not break
down when we are in good space
so mentally thank your refrigerator for
being there
for keeping your food fresh for you
thank your stove for helping you cook
all those meals
now what else do you have in your
kitchen
that you can bless with love
do that
[Music]
now now think of that modern miracle
called your bathroom
even kings and queens were not able to
experience the conveniences we take for
granted only a century ago
so bless the plumbing system that so
easily and simply removes the waste
products
the hot and cold water that is so
readily available to us when we just
turn a small knob
the convenience of being able to bathe
our bodies whenever we desire
these are all miracles
bless the radio you listen to
and the television that entertains you
[Music]
let us be grateful for the telephone
that brings us love and communications
with people everywhere
[Music]
bless your mailbox and the postal
service that helps us communicate with
people all over this planet called earth
in just a few days time
it's a miracle
that we take for granted
let us be thankful for the air that we
breathe
which is so precious to us
and we take so for granted
when we exhale
we don't even think about where our next
breath is coming from
yet this incredible power
that has created us
has given us enough breath to last
for as long as we shall live
let us be thankful for the sunshine
and the rain
without the rain the vegetation would
die
and we would have a barren planet
without beauty or food
[Music]
let us be thankful for the wind that
clears the skies
and the beauty of the moonlight
bless the vegetation that feeds and
nourishes you
whenever i eat i bless the food with
love
and i thank it for giving its life to
nourish me
now think of the clothing you wear
think of the infinite choices we have of
colors and fabrics to adorn and comfort
our bodies
if it is hot we can choose light cool
clothing
if it is cold we can choose warm cozy
fabrics to comfort us
think of the miracle called walking
[Music]
how wonderful it is
to be able to get up and to move to
another place by walking
thank your feet
for taking you so many places in the
world
then look at all the other forms of
transportation we have to choose from
[Music]
and be thankful for
there are roller skates
and skateboards and bicycles
and buses and trucks
and automobiles and trains and
aeroplanes
and ships that sail upon the waters
we have our choice
and we take them so for granted
how often have you been angry when your
automobile did not perform perfectly
bless your car with love
and be aware of the miracle it is to be
able to get into this comfortable piece
of machinery
that moves you about this planet
with very few manipulations we move
forward to our destination
it's one of our daily miracles
the next time your plane is delayed
release the tendency to be angry
instead
acknowledge the incredible ability
to be able to get into a little metal
tube that rises up in the sky
and swiftly takes us
to another place on this planet
it is one of our safest forms of
transportation
and planes need love
just as we do
[Music]
let your mind go over the various
relationships you have in your life
[Music]
bless them all with love
and be thankful for them
[Music]
they are all your teachers
i know you have special things in your
life that you are thankful for
so take a moment
to let your mind gently and lovingly
move throughout your life
past or present
giving thanks
for places
people
[Music]
or experiences
that either have been
or are now in your life
it's such a wonderful feeling to be
thankful
it prepares and opens the way
for more good to come into our lives
there is a power and a presence
that resides within us
that is always there to lead us and to
guide us
and make smooth and easy our way
all we need to do
is to acknowledge this
and to allow it to work for us
too often when we awaken in the morning
we leap out of bed
and try to push our way through life
controlling everything in sight
but that's not how this power works
it's like trying to control your
breathing
or your heartbeat
or your digestion
[Music]
if you try
all you do is interfere and upset the
natural rhythm and flow
of your bodily processes
the best thing we can do for our body
is to feed it natural foods and
beverages
to exercise it in ways that are a
pleasure to us
and to allow the intelligence in the
body
to take care of all the rest
so it is with our lives
we think positive loving thoughts
we forgive others
we are kind to ourselves mentally
and then we allow the intelligence of
the universe to take over
and create
that which is for our highest good
and greatest joy
this way the process works smoothly
the power that created us
has given us the power
to create our lives
the power and choice of the thoughts we
think
we have infinite choice
of that which we can choose to think
these choices
create our future
if we choose hurt and anger and
resentment
then we will just create more hurt and
anger and resentment
if we want love
we must think loving thoughts
if we want joy
we must think joy
if we want to experience peace and calm
then we must think peaceful thoughts
if we want prosperity
then we must open ourselves to it
mentally
if we want to flow creatively
then we must acknowledge our ability
say this with me mentally
[Music]
i
am an open channel for divine ideas to
flow through me
and the creativity of the universe
now expresses through me
[Applause]
[Music]
that which i need to know
is revealed to me
and whatever i need comes to me
[Music]
[Applause]
i am divinely protected and guided
and my way is made smooth and easy
[Music]
one of the things that creates so many
problems for us
is thoughts of anger and resentment and
blame
so let us take a moment before we
actively begin our day
to consciously dissolve that
from within our mind
[Music]
please join me in saying
i release all need
for anger or resentment or blame
i truly forgive
all those that need forgiving
and i forgive myself
i look forward to this day
with love and peace and joy
and anticipation of abundant good
in every area
[Music]
wherever you are going today
send love ahead to that place
if you are going shopping
then send love ahead of you
to the market
or the store
to the building itself
to all the merchandise in it
to all the people
to the customers
to the employees and the owners
[Music]
know that you will be guided
to make the perfect selections that will
benefit you the most
and both you and the store
will be blessed and prospered
do the same thing
if you're going to have something
repaired
or if you are going to see a lawyer or a
doctor or a dentist
if you are going to work this morning
then do the same thing
send love ahead of you
to your place of business
to the building
to the people you work with and the
people you work for
to the furniture
and equipment that you use
and to anything else you will come in
contact with
[Music]
let us declare together
that this is a healthy harmonious
loving
prosperous and creative day for you
that it is filled with joy
that you welcome change and adventure
that you bring new experiences
and new people into your life
if there is anyone that you expect to
meet today that irritates you in any way
just bless them with love
bless them with love
and the love that you send to them
will return to you multiplied
and you will benefit in ways you cannot
even imagine
whatever we give out
returns to us
as you go through this day say over and
over to yourself
two or three hundred times is barely
enough
i
approve of myself
i approve of myself
say it with me right now aloud
i
approve of myself
i am worth loving
i am willing to change
and learn a new way of expressing and
experiencing life
i now begin to accept myself
exactly
as i am
i approve of myself
[Music]
let this day be filled with love for you
let this day be peaceful
and calm
[Music]
let this day bring new insights
new understandings
let this day bring unexpected prosperity
let this be a day of great joy
this is your day
this is a good day
it is a new day
this is one of the best days
you have ever had
this is a new beginning
go forth and enjoy all that there is
i love you
and we will be together again tonight
to close the day
[Music]
take some nice deep breaths now
feel the energy filling your body
open your eyes
stretch
[Music]
get up
go forth
and enjoy it all sit comfortably in your
chair
or cross legged on the floor
place your palms facing upward
roll your shoulders back
and gently close your eyes
[Music]
take a deep breath in
and release
[Music]
identify any area in your body where you
hold on to anxiety
fear
tension
[Music]
and take a deep breath into that space
in your body
[Music]
and on the exhale
let it go
continue this cycle of breath throughout
this meditation
breathing into that feeling
and on the exhale letting it go
[Music]
we can ride the waves of these emotions
and dive into these waves
allowing ourselves to release
[Music]
tension and anxiety
in your mind's eye
see yourself standing
in a vast
blue ocean
in the distance you see the waves coming
towards you
and these waves represent your emotions
your anxieties
your fears
but they do not have to take over
because as the wave
comes upon you
you take a deep breath in
and feel all that is coming up for you
and on the exhale
you dive
into the wave
[Music]
coming out the other side
you sigh
with relief
as you see the next wave approaching
you take a deep breath in
on the exhale
[Music]
dive
into the wave
coming out the other side
with a sigh of relief
the waves come more slowly now
as you see the new wave approaching it's
a little smaller
taking a deep breath and feeling all the
waves of emotions
and on the exhale
diving
into the wave
as you release
and come out the other side
[Music]
now you notice yourself breathing long
and deep
the next wave comes and it's even
smaller now
[Music]
take a deep breath in feel all the waves
of emotions anxiety and tension that's
just coming up for you
and on the exhale release it as you dive
in to the wave
and come out the other side
take another deep breath in and release
as you see the waves are further and
further away in the distance
breathing long and deep
in between each wave
[Music]
as an even smaller wave approaches you
just take a gentle breath in feeling any
remnants of that anxiety
and on the exhale
dive into the wave
come out the other side
now there's only one last wave in the
distance
breathing long and deep as you see it
coming towards you
it's a tiny little wave
you take a deep breath in feeling the
last remnants of anxiety
and on the exhale you dive into this
small wave
coming out the other side
you feel great relief
as you look ahead there's no more waves
so you can lie back
and float in the ocean
breathing long and deep
noticing with every exhale you release
even more resistance
even more tension
breathing in
and releasing
enjoy
the sun on your face
as you float
in the beautiful ocean
breathing long and deep
[Music]
take another deep breath in
and release
as you're floating on your back in the
ocean
wiggle your fingers and your toes
[Music]
gently flutter your feet
bring your body back into a vertical
position
finding your feet
in the sand
and breathing long and deep see yourself
just gently walking out of the water
walking to the warm
sandy beach
[Music]
breathing long and deep
leaving the ocean
walking back to shore
sitting at the shore
with your feet in the water
just breathe long and deep as you stare
at the beautiful still
ocean in front of you
the stillness of the ocean represents
the stillness
in your energy
breathe in
[Music]
and release
breathe in
[Music]
and release
take this stillness with you
wherever you go
and know that you could always
dive into the waves of emotion
and come out the other side
so i just want you to close your eyes
and i want you to listen to me you're
going to be totally relaxed totally
relaxed just sit and relax let yourself
relax you're going to totally relax
totally
let your body relax you're going to stay
awake you're not going to go to sleep
and you're going to be totally relaxed
you're going to listen every word i say
you just listen to my voice you listen
nothing but my voice you only hear my
voice
your body is going to remain exactly as
it is you're not going to go to sleep
you're going to be consciously aware of
everything i say
it's going to be very clear in your mind
just as the chair under you is clear in
your mind
you hear my voice you hear nothing but
my voice all right everything i say is
energy that's flowing from me and it's
flowing through you we make a very
strong connection
i want you to imagine your whole body
moving into a very relaxed state
you're not going to go to sleep you'll
remain upright on your chair
but your body is becoming lighter and
lighter
your whole being is totally relaxed
totally relaxed
i just want you to hear my voice you
hear nothing but my voice
you're letting everything i'm saying
flow right into your consciousness it is
the most magnificent feeling you
actually feel the energy flowing into
your consciousness
you're so totally relaxed
it's flowing to and through you
i'm gonna count from five down to one
each time i count a number you're gonna
let yourself sink deeper and deeper into
a relaxed state you hear every word i'm
saying you hear everything i'm saying
and you're totally relaxed
totally relaxed each time i go down one
number you find your body becoming more
and more relaxed
you're totally relaxed we're going down
now from five to four to three and
you're sinking deeper and deeper into a
relaxed state
you feel so
good
now we're going down to three to two to
one
and you're so relaxed
you're so totally relaxed
there's a wonderful feeling i mean you
won't hear my voice you're nothing but
my voice
and you and i are going to step on an
elevator
and this elevator is going to go down
it's going down
we're on the 10th floor we're going down
to the first floor
each time we get on the floor your body
becomes more and more relaxed
we're going down from 10 to 9 8 7
you're becoming more and more relaxed
your body's lighter
lighter and lighter
you only hear my voice you hear nothing
but my voice you're totally relaxed
we're going down now
six
[Music]
five to four to three
you are so relaxed
two and one and you're totally relaxed
as the elevator doors open
you're gonna step into your room of
images
this is like a celestial place it is the
most beautiful room you have ever been
in
there's nothing like it
absolutely nothing like it everything
is just phenomenal
the doors open
and now you step into your room of
images
this is where you go when you want to be
good to you
[Music]
now you're finding yourself in a very
relaxed place you're laying down
and you're totally relaxed totally
relaxed
totally relaxed you just hear my voice
you hear nothing but my voice
you can actually feel the energy flowing
into your being
and your body's becoming more and more
relaxed
more and more relaxed
now as i put my hands on your shoulder
you're going to feel a charge of energy
that is unreal
it's going to move into your body every
molecule in your body is beginning to
become strong and healthy and alert
second i put my hands on you you're
gonna feel
the energy just like a rush of energy
it's moving into every cell of your
being
and your body is becoming stronger
and healthier and more relaxed
there just feel that
feel that energy flowing into you
it's such a beautiful energy
and it's charging every cell in your
being
you have a feeling now of health
there's a dynamic that you're feeling
that you have never experienced
you're seeing now that you're going to
move into a place of prosperity
where money will never be a problem
it's just going to keep fixing itself
it's going to keep getting better until
you are in a
financial situation
it's so good
and your body's becoming healthier and
healthier
stronger and stronger
and you're totally relaxed totally
relaxed you just hear my voice
this beautiful energy is flowing to and
through you
and understand every word i'm saying is
recorded in your brain
and in a millisecond you can go back
into this magnificent state that you
experience right now
you can do it on a crowded subway you're
in charge of you
you are controlling the vibration of the
body your body is moving into a
healthier
more dynamic
more powerful vibration and you're
staying in it constantly
i'm going to put a coin in your hand
and you're going to make certain that
coin is with you wherever you go
one side is e
that's the environment that's thinking
the way all people think about almost
all things the other side
is the g
[Music]
and that's where
you're working in harmony with god's
laws
[Music]
that's the power for everything there
ever was or ever will be
it's flowing to and through you and
it'll give you everything you asked for
you're so totally relaxed totally
relaxed
it's a magnificent feeling you're
experiencing
you're so totally relaxed
totally relaxed
totally relaxed i'm going to put this
under your palm on your right hand
and you're going to feel that and
there's a feeling come with it
the g is pressing against your hand
understand
that is a physical instrument that
represents an infinite power
that's the spirit of god flown to and
through you
and it will give you whatever you ask
for
it will keep you in an absolutely
magnificent healthy vibration
it will keep you in such a prosperous
vibration that your financial situation
will continually improve day in day out
it will keep you in such a wonderful
vibration that you will find yourself
surrounded by people who are good people
they care and their friendships like you
have never heard of
this is such a magnificent vibration you
attract all things to you that are good
you're in that vibration now you have
let yourself go there everything i'm
saying is programmed deep into your
marvelous mind
[Music]
let yourself experience this
deep
meaningful feel of gratitude
you're totally relaxed i'm gonna count
from one to ten
each time i count a number you're going
to move up you're going to feel like
there's phenomenal charges of energy
flowing to and through you
there's just enormous charges of energy
on the count of 10 you're going to open
your eyes you're going to have a smile
on your face you're going to feel like
you've had a wonderful rest
each time i count a number from one to
ten new energy will flow into you
it's the most magnificent experience in
everything i've said everything that is
programmed into your mind it's in cells
in your brain it's there at will
understand the body cannot be ill in
healthy vibration understand the person
could not be poor in a prosperous
vibration understand the person cannot
be alone and lonely when they're in a
great areas
loving relationships vibration
everything in your life is going to get
better for you every every aspect of
there's nothing that you can touch that
isn't going to improve everything's
going to improve because
you've got that touch
you've got the magic
you're going to do things you never
dreamt of
you're so relaxed
it's so powerful
so powerful
so
[Music]
coming up from one
two
three you're feeling new energy flow
into you it's just coming in from every
section of your being every spot in your
body we're up to four and five it's a
phenomenal energy you can feel it it's
just lifting you to a higher level
you're up to six to seven to eight
there's a phenomenal power moving into
you it's a feeling like you've never
experienced on the count of ten you're
going to open your eyes as if you feel
like you've had a wonderful rest read 7
10.
now
just relax
and let yourself be aware of what we've
been doing
we're asking
ask and you'll receive
what whatever you ask for
you ask in the form of thought
don't ask talk or think about anything
you don't want
just ask
think
and receive graciously receive
everything you want
the trick is
willingly give
and graciously receive
[Music]
every aspect of your life
now i want you to listen to this often
i want you to listen to it often i want
you to listen to it and understand this
is being directed with and through you
and it's going to keep getting stronger
and you're going to live healthier
happier more fulfilled lives
[Music]
you're totally relaxed totally relaxed
eyes
[Laughter]
take a breath
[Applause]
[Music]
for love
into your heart
[Music]
and exhale
[Applause]
[Music]
relax
[Applause]
[Music]
into your heart
feel it
[Music]
notice it
your heart
[Laughter]
and breathe a little love
into your heart
and exhale
[Laughter]
and relax
into your heart
and breathe in for love
[Music]
and exhale
[Applause]
[Music]
and rely
and let a little more love
into your heart
[Music]
and breathe for love
into your heart
[Music]
and that's half
[Applause]
and relax
let love
[Music]
into your heart
and let the thought
[Music]
of someone you love
bring up the feeling of love
in your heart
feel it
[Music]
hold them in that feeling
in your heart
[Music]
hold them
in your heart
[Music]
feel it
now put their heart
[Applause]
in your heart
[Music]
and feel your love for them
[Applause]
in your heart
[Music]
that's your love
you're giving them
[Music]
in their heart
[Applause]
feel it
[Music]
that's energy
in your heart
in their heart
[Music]
that's your energy
in their heart
[Music]
that's love
your love
[Music]
in their heart
that's love
in your heart
[Music]
feel it
[Applause]
experience it
[Music]
enjoy it
[Applause]
that's the love you want them to
[Music]
in feel heart
feel it
[Music]
in your heart
feel your connection to them
[Music]
in your heart
one heart
[Music]
that's love
in one heart
feel it
and become one
in your heart
[Music]
that's love
your love
[Music]
for their heart
that's your love
in your heart
[Music]
feel it
in your heart
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's energy
in your heart
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a little more oneness
in your hearts
[Music]
hmm
that's your connection
to love
in your heart
that's the feeling
[Music]
you want people you love
to feel in their hearts
[Music]
and remember
this feeling
[Music]
know it
my heart
[Music]
that's life
in your heart
[Music]
who do you want to be
when you open your eyes
in your heart
feel it
[Music]
[Applause]
your heart
[Music]
when you're ready
you can open your eyes
come back
to the realm of space and time
[Applause]
remember
[Music]
there's love in your heart
sit comfortably in a cross-legged
posture
keep your spine comfortably erect
we will hold yoga mudra
make the thumb
and the index finger come together at
the very tips forming a circle between
them
let the other three fingers be straight
all the four fingers together without
any gap between them
holding the mudra facing upwards upon
your thigh arms and shoulders should be
loose and relaxed
close your eyes
and sit with a slightly upturned face
when you sit with your face slightly
upturned
there is a natural focus between your
eyebrows
maintain this natural focus do not
concentrate just maintain this natural
focus between your eyebrows and sit with
your face slightly upturned
eyes closed
maintain this gentle and casual focus
between the eyebrows
and be conscious of the natural moment
of breath
continue to sit like this for three to
six minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
foreign
hmm
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
take your own time
slowly
very slowly
open your eyes
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag
in the comments below on this video i
will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to know the
seven reasons why you must start
meditating right now check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there if i don't do it i feel like
i'm constantly chasing the day
meditation is the art of awareness
awareness internally awareness
externally but also the various